[Applause]
you know what they're going to come for
next i bet you they start coming from
podcast
well that's the dumb part is there
that's you like oh this podcaster oh
they had ben shapiro on their podcast
it's like
you had trump and whoever else that you
hate on cnn
non-stop you were filming them for hours
just not even with backlash or
counterpoints
just filming them you're talking about
you're talking about the uh
news organizations that are calling out
podcasters yeah exactly
so okay let's talk about this in two in
two different worlds right one we'll
talk about the news organizations
calling them out in the hypocrisy there
and then we'll also talk about big tech
potentially censoring podcasts for
misinformation
let's first call out the news
organizations because exactly what you
said is true
yeah it's [ __ ] it's like you showed
up to his rallies
with a camera that has a direct feed to
your news network
yeah and now all of a sudden you're
saying we need to silence him because
his rhetoric is dangerous
the reddit the rhetoric that you sold
advertising on
millions of [ __ ] [ __ ] and on a
podcast [ __ ] you can go
yeah you can go back and forth like i
think trump on a podcast if
i mean if you believe that trump's
rhetoric is dangerous i think trump on a
podcast is
the best way to have him because you can
challenge him have counterpoints
interview
his interviews with people that pushed
him were the best interviews yeah just
putting him at a rally with all these
people cheering him on if you're like an
undecided voter you're like oh
people seem to like this guy every
interview where he had that was
unfiltered
exposed the con right like and you
got tons of news coverage on it
afterwards
where people said see this is what we've
been pointing out
right when you just expose
him in his vacuum speaking to the people
that support everything in that bag
thousands of people in a field sharing
them on
you make him look like a [ __ ] deity
yep
you are responsible for this balls on
this and if you're a borderline trump
supporter and you see all these other
people supporting him
how much easier is it to go to that side
i'm not alone i'm not a freak if i like
trump
yeah this guy's known he must be saying
something that's got truth to it mm-hmm
yeah they built the the cult of
personality they they definitely helped
build it without a doubt
right and then they have the i think
that's the thing is the gal to come back
and say the podcasts and
people that are willing to have on
controversial figures oh wait wait wait
are they calling out the people they're
competing with now
so i mean they do this all the time but
like this is i i think actually
uh the rising we're talking about i
think sega was talking about it but
basically
the ap put out some articles suggesting
that podcasts ap is the associated press
yeah this is for anybody listening
yeah so basically it is a news network
that's supposedly unbiased and it just
gives you
the news yeah right and they put out pp
is actually pretty realistic
they're normally good and i think the
headline was a little bit more salacious
than the actual like
body of the article but basically what
the headline was is that
they were suggesting that these people
were getting censored and banned off of
platforms but they're still able to use
podcast portals as a way to reach their
audience and they're talking about like
uh what they would call quote unquote
radical alt-right
conservative like commentators and they
say these people are dangerous and they
have dangerous rhetoric that kind of
spreading misinformation yeah
misinformation misinformation is key
because
that's what you can use as a reason a
rationale
for uh blackballing someone removing
something from a platform right so yeah
they get banned off twitter but they're
able to then just have a podcast and use
some rss feed and then push their
podcast out
and safety yeah we need to silence those
voices now these things are very
different than having a twitter and a
facebook and a podcast because
you're not interacting directly with
your podcast uh
host right like on twitter you can
galvanize and organize
people and say and communicate and say
this is where we're going to meet
facebook is incredibly effective for
this as well
create these groups and share
information podcast is literally an
album you're listening to it for two
hours live shows of the podcast
say again you can do podcast live shows
you can communicate to people but they
can't communicate back to you and to
each other
right and i think that's where there's a
little bit of a discrepancy and where
things a little safer but continue
so the article is like i think there
were some people that were like
quote unquote legitimate dangerous
forces that were like calling to kill
people
and then we're using podcasts as a
avenue to do it
and so in like this is the tricky part
with any type of censorship is that in
the reasonable cases it seems like a
good idea but then the question is where
does it stop and who controls where the
line's drawn
yeah and no one has an answer to that
which is why people get anxious but like
if you're like oh should we stop child
predators from having podcasts to talk
to each other everyone's like yeah
yeah should we top people that are
trying to kill politicians blah blah
yeah probably we should and then you
hear a conversation that we have on here
and they go oh
politicians should get shot in the head
and then all of a sudden yeah they're
calling for their fans to
to murder politicians yeah and now they
have the right to potentially wipe us
off
yeah it's it sucks this is the
over-correction that often happens when
there's any censorship
but i do think podcasts will be the next
thing that they come for
and it's absolute [ __ ] and the fact
that news organizations that have
propped these [ __ ] that they
say they hate up
and made so much money off them like
we're talking about
nobody has made more money than cnn off
of trump true nobody
very true he was included i don't think
fox because i think what often happens
is
you make more money when the opposition
is in office you've made more money
ratings of all time like they would have
even better ratings
i imagine if you think oh people hate
watching
yes no no wait because you want to watch
to [ __ ] on
so when the person is in power you're
watching to [ __ ] on so cnn's killing it
because the person in power is not
aligned with their politics
so you're [ __ ] on that person and
they're giving you reasons why you hate
them
hey feed me more reasons why they're
stupid feed me more reasons i don't like
this guy tell me why
that's essentially what those are just
doing on your loss for four years but
they're beside that one is like yeah
and fox is just doing on like liberals
response to the loss
exactly so it's like oh aoc said this
thing blah blah blah and then they just
galvanize the people right they create
their villains and then they just sell
their [ __ ] today but couldn't an
out for any podcaster just be like oh um
anything i say on here is in fact it's
just my opinion and you're just safe
so you could do the bill o'reilly uh
excuse and the hannity excuse which is
we're just entertainers
we're not news not a news organization
even though fox's
slogan is literally the truth yeah
really something
crazy like no spin zone exactly and then
their
[ __ ] asses once they were called out
started just calling themselves
entertainers
now we're entertainers
no but you know we've we've never
claimed to be anything else right it's
comedy podcast
you know was a sports podcast you
couldn't even be consistent with that
but the point is but the point is it's
absolutely hypocritical for these
[ __ ] to make all this money and
sudden starts
silencing people and maybe the reason
they're silencing
me
i might have one i had an obama moment
it's your fault he's on the back for my
homes right now
but it's just so [ __ ] infuriating man
you are silencing your competition
you're taking advantage of a moment to
silence your competition that's what i
see
they see that podcasts have way more
influence on these news organizations
and they see that so many more people
are listening to
maybe right wing conservative uh podcast
what's the guy's name
uh car uh stephen crowder crowder yeah
crowder way more people are probably
watching him that are watching
you know some fledgling cnn show i think
during
election night his live stream was
watched more than cnn's i think it was
like competitive i think it was like
cnn another one and then like his was
like the third stephen crowder he's like
uh
like a republican like news commentator
but there are some that are pretty like
there's one
uh called like the daily showa which is
holocaust showa means holocaust so the
daily uh
that's like there's no doubt that
there's super [ __ ] up ones that
we can get out of here there's no
question so that's where it gets tricky
is okay
that seems reasonable to me that you
would get rid of a podcast called the
daily holocaust
yes but like then where's the line if
you're going to get rid of those
how do you know when the end is what i'm
saying is i think that these
organizations are going to use this
as an excuse to wipe out some
competition
and it sucks man yeah it really sucks
because
nobody's calling out the fact that they
made billions of dollars off of this guy
that they supposedly hate
like when they were racking in those
billions of dollars yeah they weren't
that [ __ ] up
you know what i'm saying like i thought
facebook was like a piece of [ __ ]
platform super [ __ ] up
and then mark showed me this uh
analytics of how much money we make a
month and now i think it's a reasonable
you know social media platform right
that the world needs yeah
it's very important and mark
zuckerberg's doing an absolutely
fantastic job when he's doing the gospel
yeah he's
literally doing god's work so if he
needs to go [ __ ] scuba diving or
surfing
in hawaii and use tons of spf on his
face do whatever you need to do as long
as those [ __ ] checks keep
coming thank you so much that's the
beauty of not being a news network yeah
all right stepping up twitter i don't
make any money off of you
at least you're honest if cnn was like
hey man we made a lot of money with this
guy
i don't mind if he gets four more years
yeah bet i would love that
bet it just be isn't it refreshing when
these [ __ ] just tell you the
truth
oh yeah yeah because i don't know what
the actual endgame is
yeah yeah the devil you know it's just i
don't know maybe i just see like
fraudulence yeah in someone and i know
it's there
yeah and it just drives me [ __ ] crazy
when they won't admit it like you ever
know like you ever catch someone in a
lie and you're just like
[ __ ] yeah just tell me the truth
yeah it's up
it's yeah what is called the jig is up
yeah it's i get it i see it and if you
told me truth i wouldn't even be that
mad
but now you're insulting my intelligence
by trying to continue to lie to me
that's when i'm upset
i think i'm back to shooting them bro i
think i'm back
i think i might be back i don't know
maybe it's a hard job
maybe maybe it's a hard job being a
politician i don't see it as being that
hard
it's hard is it you need no skills i
don't believe it you're a representative
you know c
was making margaritas i know but you're
representing a bunch of people you got
to please
everybody and try to keep your job at
the same time it's like
like you could never do the right thing
i would never do it because i don't
think that like that's how you actually
make change i think you make
actual change way more effective when
you can affect culture
itself not through legislation but um no
you could affect change with legislation
yeah but i think you first need to like
get the people on your side and then you
get legislation you're more disruptive
outside the system and then the system
responds
mlk a perfect example exactly but then
he didn't make any change until he
started working within the system right
but he changed the culture
enough for the people to want it like
you look at like a book like uncle tom's
cabin harriet beecher stowe wrote this
like
really graphic novel about slavery and
before that up in the north
people had this kind of like idyllic
look about slavery they're like oh it's
not that bad it's just like uh
yeah they're working together and
everything's kind of cool and you know
isn't it nice you to work and have a
place to live and eat and then she's
writing this art this not about them
getting like whipped and bleeding and
families torn apart and people are like
yo what the [ __ ] is going on and you
really see that people in like the
abolitionist movement at that time start
to get galvanized
yeah so it's like i want to do that
stuff got you gotcha
and then you make the legislation that
we disrupted
into place you could get all the credit
if you want as like a senator for making
the legislation i don't give a [ __ ] but
you do what i do
got you you know what i'm saying you do
what we create
you're not gonna impose on us because
every time they impose [ __ ] on us
without us wanting it we reject yeah
that's why they got to trick us into all
these wars and [ __ ]
like every single war you got to trick
us into you know what i'm saying
you saw vice yeah how can they trick us
into going to iraq
yeah how can they trick us into going to
vietnam how can they trick us into going
to world war ii
you got to get us on board with whatever
policy you want to change
yeah the vietnam rationale was just so
[ __ ] weird
yeah if they become communists that'll
start a domino effect and then
everybody will become communist and
domino's
any other takeaways with that with
what's what's essentially happening
yeah i mean it's just it's exactly what
you were saying it's just going to be
tricky when
like obviously the bad things should go
the good thing should stay
like the whole the [ __ ] rest of the
world's in the middle you know what i
mean like yeah
they got hard conversations about like
life that are like
insensitive but are like intellectual
conversations like
should they get banned should they not i
don't think so hopefully the
technocratic demigods that run our world
will
see the way you see it well here's the
thing
here's the thing if we're talking about
the technocratic demigods
i don't know if we spoke about this
[ __ ] tech lords that run
all all right you know zuckerberg all
these guys so
this is an interesting thing that's
happening in the world i don't know if
we spoke about it on this podcast maybe
we spoke on patreon but like
america okay so you heard about like
jack ma
right yes and the billionaire jack mais
the richest guy in china i think we
maybe spoke about flagrant a little bit
right
um and how he was just ghosted for like
two months
yeah right apparently he's still alive
but i don't know if [ __ ] really
heard from him like that
but they basically removed him from his
seat at alibaba which is like
the biggest it's like amazon there we
spoke about this with the drop shipping
and everything like that
but china is going through the same
thing america is going through
only their reaction to it as a
totalitarian regime would react
they're going yo you're not gonna have
more control than us we're the
government
and america is reacting to it the way
america would act but oh i'm sorry big
business
do as you wish yeah oh you guys want to
cancel people off your platforms even
though it might
technically be a violation of free
speech or whatever
by all means you know what i'm saying
don't get me wrong i'm cool with
[ __ ] getting taken off these
platforms that are just
absolute [ __ ] i don't need a daily
holocaust show yeah
that being said some people might fight
for free speech
yeah you agree that there should be some
or you believe this should be
i just think it's it's tough because you
have to look at each situation as each
situation
imagine being the guy who's like i want
to talk about how the holocaust didn't
exist
every day free speech
yeah what an [ __ ] yeah like you were
ruining it for everybody
yeah it's just also mad boring like find
a new topic what is this
how many times can you say this didn't
happen every day
isn't there a metaphor for this there's
a metaphor for this like uh when people
take advantage of the situation it's
like
it's like your parents go okay you don't
have a curfew and then you like
every night stay out til 4 a.m yeah your
parents like why are you
making me impose laws yeah yes
why are you making now i gotta impose
laws on the whole family because you
need to take advantage of the freedom
that i gave you yeah mark
that's
right like how do we articulate that
feeling is this
yeah it's like a free ridership like ev
like everyone else has to
you basically make the rule you break
the not real rule to then make the rule
yeah now
yeah you're forcing me to make the rule
yeah there should be no law against rape
you know what i mean you just shouldn't
rape like it's just
like you don't mean everyone should just
know that you shouldn't do that but then
enough people were doing like god damn
we gotta make this a [ __ ]
[ __ ] rape on a technicality
that's crazy yeah you're a hundred
percent
like you should just not [ __ ] young
girls yeah
then they make it a lot and now some
people are out here at high schools just
lurking around we're like are we always
here
we got to literally make a rule that
says you're not allowed to sleep with
these girls
you're going to make us do this yeah
that's who you are
that's the daily show and that's these
other [ __ ] pot you're the people
the reason why we have don't rape people
lost yeah same thing
we don't need these things we don't need
don't murder
yeah we don't need it yeah cause none of
us are gonna walk around murdering we're
gonna walk around going [ __ ] i
would kill you if i wasn't
crazy if i was crazy yeah
because there's like reasonable voices
on the left and right that are trying to
have discussion
but if you are having discussion that
people see is potentially dangerous then
you get got and you know what's
unfortunate is that like
the left and right will never be able to
see
each other for who they really are and
how they really feel as long as those
extremes exist
yeah because and we spoke about in shoal
saves america right the opposition will
always paint
right yep the other side as their worst
case scenario yes
right so like to the average republican
the average left-wing person
is bernie sanders yeah they're not just
a little bit left to center their aoc
yeah
even the extreme case of socialist is a
communist is it does that mean like
this guy wants to take away your freedom
they want to make us the ussr right
enough for bread like yeah and the
opposite right yeah
so like to the average like left-wing
people can't just be a trump supporter
because you don't like high taxes
that's it you have to be a racist you
are a you are a racist if you support
trump in any way shape or form
and it's like i don't think that's
necessarily true no
you don't care about minorities not
enough to pay that much in taxes
that's that's all it is and if you knew
it
if you knew as few minorities as i know
and made as much money as i did you will
see where i'm coming from
you know it's mad funny because just
today the guy from florida
um he said uh mark what's that
no the one i think scott something scott
rick scott
yeah rick scott yeah skeletor skeletor
looking ass [ __ ]
he said um because they're talking about
like a bailout for the cities like 340
million or a billion dollar bailout so
some of these cities can get some money
in america and he's like
why should florida bail out new york
like we don't have anything to do with
y'all he's right
and it's reasonable right like now don't
get me wrong
if some country invades florida you're
going to want new york
to bail out florida exactly right bro
who's going to invade florida bro
who can touch florida come on son
cuban's been invading florida enough for
a long time
come on in you all are really yeah but
you've got a policy you're like just get
here
yeah if you can't beat us join us that's
what they say you know
how different is the the policy
uh for cubans versus mexicans that is
hilarious yeah i don't know why mexicans
are
like trying to just pretend to be cuban
literally you're not going to know the
difference
yeah literally pull up get okay
get a [ __ ] cuban shirt or something
like that what the [ __ ] is that cubans
just need to put a
foot on the dry land and they are
american
mexicans that's true need to live here
legally for 30 years
yeah just show up and they go are you
mexican go no i'm cuban i lost my id
i just got here through mexico i'm cuban
i got here through mexico yeah no you're
not
how would you know anything about cuban
you know what i mean were you a traitor
you're hanging out in cuba you're not
even allowed to go there
yeah use the racism to your advantage
dumb ass mexicans y'all could have been
coming here so easily
yeah people [ __ ] what's wrong with
you mistaking you guys for different you
know
hispanic all the time like just use that
to be you know that's where pride kills
you bro
hispanics too proud yeah coming in with
a mexican flag around your shoulders cut
that [ __ ] out bro
you are cuban a big ass cigar i wonder
if that's the plan for some of them
they're like i'm going to go there i'm
going to pretend to be cuban i'm cuban
i'm cubans they shut up are you cuban
mexican [ __ ] dude i had this whole plan
viva la mexico that's hilarious like you
just at the immigration place and like
in the background they just started
putting on a canelo fight and they're
like well what's happening over here
i didn't realize canelo was fighting
today bro that's the trick they sit you
down they start playing mariachi you
know so you start dancing and you're
like oh rose in the other room with some
nutella you're like
wait what's that